vorsicht auf der autobahn hier entkommt
ein kopf knapp einer kollision mit einem
anderen wagen
auf der interstate 84 kommt dass laut
polizei zu einem zusammenstoß von sechs
fahrzeugen dabei gibt es einen
verletzten und das ist dieser kopp der
hier ins alte mann rückwärts über eine
absperrung springen muss um einem
herannahenden pkw auszuweichen bei der
landung verletzt er sich wo später ins
krankenhaus gebracht werden
der polizist stand mit seinem
streifenwagen an der mittelleitplanke
der autobahn um einem liegengebliebenen
autofahrer zu helfen dabei kam es zur
kollision mit vier anderen fahrzeugen
bis auf den kopf wurde niemand verletzt